[Music]
thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story history captured the first
official photographs of King Charles III
are released as he calls the nation's
support the greatest possible coronation
gift
a working royal family where even the
very youngest pitch in as part of
volunteering efforts across the country
millions of others have been giving
their time to create a legacy of
volunteering marking the starts of the
king's reign
but a legal threat against the Met as
police Express regrets that
anti-monarchy protesters were arrested
ahead of the ceremony
plus beating the 8 A.M scramble more
money for systems to book GP
appointments
blackened buildings in the Ukrainian
Capital as Moscow launches what key of
authorities say are the biggest drone
strikes yet
Trump on trial again closing arguments
begin in the Civil rape case against the
former president
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in The Press
preview at 10 30.
[Music]
hello a very good evening thanks for
joining us King Charles has called the
nation's support through the
celebrations the greatest possible
coronation gift as the palace released
the first official photographs of the
newly crowned king and queen Charles and
Camilla kept a lower profile today
allowing other members of the royal
family including the king's
grandchildren to take center stage in a
huge volunteering effort in honor of the
coronation but one point of controversy
from the weekend escalated this evening
with the head of anti-monarchy group
arrested on the day calling for an
inquiry into what he called a
disgraceful episode and the Met police
expressing regret more on that in a
moment but first our Royal correspondent
Laura bundock reports
seat
learning the ropes and stealing the show
The Prince and Princess of Wales brought
the whole family to the big help out
with the scouts here in Slough
Prince George Keen to lend a hand and
Charlotte's on target with the
volunteering message the defining theme
of the weekend has been service hasn't
it and we've seen that writ large today
with the big help out and to have had
the
support of The Prince and Princess of
Wales and the rest of the family as well
just goes to show that as a family you
can get involved in volunteering
coronation aside we've never seen them
together at an engagement
no sign of Grandpa but the Firepower of
his wider family out in force the Duke
and Duchess of Edinburgh meeting guide
dogs in training and a Gloucester
Cathedral service for the Princess Royal
to thank volunteers
the coronation placed the royal family
in the spotlight for three days but
already questions on what next
generated a range of views and
interpretations and also there is
definitely now more a questioning about
the monarchy perhaps than there has been
for decades a desire for more
information about the accountability or
not and the transparency or not of the
monarchy
the fences are gone and soon Flags will
be down as the coronation comes to a
close everyone will come away with a
different memory from this weekend we've
seen spectacle on a huge scale the king
commanding the military convening world
leaders and celebrities but is it enough
to convince people the monarchy still
matters
and to that the celebrations short-lived
from official photos we have a portrait
of the working Royals the king says it
was a special occasion newly crowned but
this week straight back to work Laura
bundock Sky News
well it wasn't just senior Royals who
were out volunteering thousands of
people across the country were
encouraged to give up some of their time
today to lend a hand in their local area
scars Becca Johnson has been meeting
some of those who turned out to help
far from the pageantry Pomp and party's
litter picking in the rain rounded off
the coronation for these volunteers at a
park near Birmingham
Gary Norris brought his three-year-old
son Samuel along to help I'm a teacher
at a local school in Birmingham and
we've been doing a lot of citizenship in
in lessons so
um rather than just telling them that
there's something that they could be
doing I you know I wanted to experience
it myself and come out and help
the sparse landscape the result of a
wildfire Here In the Heat of last summer
likely sparked by sunlight on broken
glass
the big help out took place in rather
cooler damper conditions this is a
one-off event for the coronation but
many organizations need volunteers the
year round and they're hopeful that by
coming along to this people will want to
offer their services more often in Leeds
volunteers tended horses that are
Stables where disabled children and
adults can go riding
while in Banbury a game of pin the
diamond on the crown was part of a day
of activities to encourage more people
to sign up for regular volunteering
that's a good one if you've got spare
time please join us volunteer and do as
much as you can for the community for
some of the elderly people who come here
it's a Lifeline from loneliness they've
taken me out and brought me here and
I've seen all these people have made
many friends
oh wow okay during a cost of living
crisis that's left thousands reliant on
voluntary Services even the Prime
Minister and his wife got stuck in now
this is part of the big help out tens of
thousands of events taking place across
the country just like this respecting
and reflecting that his Majesty's long
tradition of service and it's Community
Spirit like this that binds our country
together
no Royal event would be complete
complete without a bit of planting so
Volunteers in Green Park in London were
hard at work it really builds that sense
of community in the UK and really just
giving back and for us the Royal Parks
is really feels really special to be
um part of that and really doing our
part to get people to give to the
environment which is obviously something
that's close to King Charles's heart
and so it's hoped that the coronation an
event so far removed from everyday life
may have helped bring local communities
closer together
Becky Johnson Sky News
meanwhile anti-monarchy campaigners who
were arrested ahead of the king's
coronation are considering League action
against the Metropolitan Police 64
people in total were arrested on
Saturday and so far only four charges
have been made six others will face no
further action Graham Smith the chief
executive of Republic called for a full
inquiry into the arrests describing it
as a disgraceful episode well tonight
the Metropolitan Police have issued a
statement saying our activity was
targeted at those we believed were
intent on taking this action it was not
Our intention to prevent protest and
whilst the vast masses of the crowd were
there to celebrate and witness a once in
a generation event it is very clear a
number of protests took place across the
footprint both before during and after
the event with no police intervention
any suggestion or protest was prohibited
is not correct the force added in
relation to six of the arrests we regret
that those six people arrested were
unable to join The Wider group of
protesters in Trafalgar Square and
Elsewhere on the procession routes
well away from the coronation people
should be able to book an appointment
with their GP more easily as part of a
government pledge to improve patient
access millions of pounds of funding has
been announced for this year to help end
what the health secretary has described
as the 8 A.M Scramble for appointments
changes include introducing online
booking tools and upgrading phone
systems for disguise Health
correspondent Ashish Joshi reports some
GPS and pharmacists are questioning
whether the plans will make any
difference
we have our clinical pharmacist who
works there our physiotherapist who
works there Dr Mehta doesn't normally
have the luxury of an empty surgery to
show journalists like me around it's a
really bustling place on a Monday
morning the government wants to improve
patient access to doctors like him
firstly by spending over 2 million
pounds on new telephone systems to make
sure every patient's call is answered
it's not only about access it should be
about the continuity of care so as GP
practices we know our populations we
know our patients we know when they come
in and they are more needy than other
times so I think if we if we just look
along access and just providing them
with more and more appointments as
opposed to providing them with
Continuous Care we might end up in a bit
of trouble
600 patients are registered at this
practice and every morning sees the same
chaotic dash for appointments the
practice is closed but already the
phones are going normally you'd have
four receptionists here Fielding calls
from hundreds of patients all trying to
make appointments for that day the
government says it wants to move away
from this 8 A.M scramble the doctors
here say the situation every morning is
manic doctors want the investment but it
doesn't address the workforce crisis
that is driving the pressure in Primary
Care the numbers of GPS in the UK is
dropping
um and so you know the the ultimate real
requirement is more GPS to be able to
see the numbers of patients that are
coming through especially since demand
for general practice Services has gone
up dramatically in the last two years
the government's primary care plan will
also see high Street pharmacists taking
on more roles like prescribing
medication
and it wants to train GP receptionists
to clinically assess calls I don't think
I'd be very comfortable telling a
receptionist my problems she's not
medically trained uq don't you for ages
on the phone and then you get through
and they say there's no appointments
left I think they should start fit
properly and then pay the staff a proper
wage I think that's that's the best
thing they can do everyone shorts
laughed everyone's under pressure
and just throw in a load of cash at it I
don't think is the answer
investment in technology to give
patients better access is welcome but
the challenge is to make sure there are
enough GPS like Dr Mehta to see those
patients Ashish Josh is Sky News in
Redbridge in Essex
and our chief political correspondent
John Craig joins us now from Downing
Street so John an attempt to get on the
front foot from the government but those
terrible local election results will be
the main topic of conversation I'm sure
when Tory MPS returned to Westminster
tomorrow
the fight back starts here for Rishi
sunaka relaunch you might say we've
already heard one government
announcement on health today we're
likely to hear another one tomorrow but
of course there'll be plenty of
grumbling Tory MPS when MPS return to
Westminster tomorrow the first piece of
business for example is treasury
questions cue calls from Tory right
Wingers for tax cuts before the
chancellor wants to introduce them then
of course on Wednesday meeting of the
1922 committee back bench is bound to be
a big inquest and there's a huge round
amongst Tory MPS over housing and the
prime minister's controversial move to
scrap housing targets a lot of Tories
think that damaged the conservatives in
the local elections some of those
councils that they lost to labor and the
liberal Democrats and then at the
weekend we the Boris Johnson fan club
otherwise known as the conservative
Democratic organization they're holding
their first conference they're the ones
many of them who want to bring back
Johnson's Tory leaders speakers will
include will Jacob Reese Morgan Nadine
Doris well today the Prime Minister
remained defiant when he was asked about
apologizing to to conservative
councilors who'd lost their seats on
Thursday he refused to do so
will you apologize to the more than a
thousand councilors who lost their seats
on Friday always disappointing to lose
hard working third of counselors and I
said that at the time you know my job is
to deliver for the country and we've got
a big team of people determined to do
that we want to have inflation grow the
economy reduce their cut waiting list
and stop the vote those are the
countries priorities and me and the
government are going to keep working
incredibly hard to deliver on those
well the Prime Minister was talking at
length there twice he mentioned it about
his uh about his five point plan of
course getting waiting lists down is one
but of course up to now with the strikes
in the National Health Service they've
been any longer not shorter inflation
well food prices up towards the 20 to
inflation Mark though they're down to
about 15 now talk of more interest rate
Rises that means mortgages are going to
go up again and still no progress so
please not enough progress to please
Tory MPS on the small boat so a lot of
MPS MPS think he needs to be broadened
his appeal that for example talk more
about crime that's not one of his five
priorities why not say some Tory MPS he
just keeps sticking to the script of the
five pledges repeating them over and
over again a lot of his a lot of his
colleagues think he needs to do a lot
more and of course those results were
dreadful for the conservatives although
they are relieved that they don't put Mr
uh Starman on course from a Commons
majority the pike the fight back though
very much is on here in Downing Street
John thank you
tomorrow Russia will Mark its Victory
Day a celebration of its success in
World War II President Putin may have
wanted to secure bakmut ahead of the
celebration but Ukraine's stubborn
defense of the city has robbed him a
vast achievement and as the war rages on
Ukrainian officials were forced to issue
an air alert across the entire country
this morning after drone strikes the
Ukrainian government called the biggest
yet military analyst Sean Bell hasmore
Victory Day parades are normally a
massive event in the Russian calendar
not only in Red Square but across the
whole of the country but Russia's lost a
lot of the military equipment in this
last year it's also seeded 50 percent of
the territory in Ukraine than it once
had and as a result it's canceled many
of its parades across the main country
in addition The Immortal regiments which
are relatives of families that have lost
loved ones in the uh second world war in
the conflict often March as part of the
parade with pictures of their loved ones
in fact President Putin LED this part of
display
um of the parade last year with a
picture of his father in military
uniform this imagery is from last year
but the concern is that actually this
parade if it was run this year would
attract all those families who've lost
loved ones in the Ukraine war and that
would expose the full extent of Russia's
losses and therefore this element of the
parade has been canceled if we look more
widely though the last 10 days has seen
a massive increase the number of Russian
attacks across the country across UK
rain particularly the last 24 hours
where kharkiv curse and Mika live and
Odessa and Kiev have all been heavily
targeted over the last 24 hours attacks
include 35 Shaheed 136 drones those are
the drones that Russia is importing from
Iran and although the Ukraine is
becoming increasingly Adept at shooting
these down as could be seen from this
footage over Kiev the worry is
inevitably some of the wreckage falls on
the city and can cause some damage on
the ground mayor Klitschko has said that
at least five civilians were injured a
lot of the damages to residential
buildings very difficult to see these as
military targets but also the Russians
have fired at least 16 missiles and 61
airstrikes so it's well over 100 strikes
in the last 24 hours they've included
targeting Odessa a Food Warehouse there
and they've been Air Raid Sirens going
across the whole country so it's clear
that Ukraine is expecting more of these
attacks to come if we look at back moot
we've been talking about that mood for
the last 11 months Russia now owns 90
percent of the city but has still failed
to deliver success in times already for
the Victory Day celebration but the
question is why are both sides fighting
in back moved Ukraine always claimed
that actually on if they can force the
Russians into offense generally forces
lose three times as many soldiers in
offense they do defense Russia is an
experience they've actually been losing
about seven to one as a result Ukraine
has felt that if we don't fight them
here where are we going to fight them at
least we can attract more of the
Russians here but only this week you
have Guinea pregos in the boss of the
Wagner group has also said that's
exactly what Russia's tactics have been
for the last few months trying to grind
down Ukrainian forces the tragedy here
is both sides are fighting over what is
not as strategically important city both
sides trying to maximize the casualties
they inflict on each other what a
dreadful horror of war how on Earth you
rationalize the huge loss of life and
for what
a man accused of killing eight people
including three children after driving a
vehicle into a group near a homeless and
migrant shelter in Texas has been
charged with eight counts of
manslaughter 18 people were also injured
in Brownsville in Texas when a Land
Rover hit a group waiting at a bus stop
across the street the man is expected to
face further charges later today
back here a former ofsted inspector has
criticized the way in which the Watchdog
rates schools telling Sky News that
reducing their performance to a single
word judgment is nonsense the debate
over the inspections impact was prompted
by the death of head teacher Ruth Perry
who took her own life in January after
ofsted downgraded her school from
outstanding to inadequate calls for
reform of the sector are now growing as
Skies either Bennett reports
I cannot be silent through the tears
that keep on coming the dam has been
broken There's No Going Back
they are alarming insights into the
lives of head teachers and the
devastating impact an ofsted inspection
can have the sleepless nights the
endless crying the feeling of being a
failure
the suicide of school leader Ruth Perry
triggering painful memories for many and
he was really struggling Simon kidwell's
School in Cheshire was inspected last
month his eighth one as a head teacher
yet it still triggered his insomnia I
think it's the intensity of the process
I think it's the adrenaline because it's
very very high stakes I think if I was
to get an adequate judgment I'd be
absolutely bereft and I don't know if I
could continue in education
Ruth Perry's family says she felt the
same way the head teacher took her own
life in January after an inspection that
would downgrade her school in Reading
from outstanding to inadequate but this
tragedy is by no means an isolated case
in the last 25 years there have been at
least 10 teachers who have taken their
own life where the stress of an ofsted
inspection has been cited in the
coroner's report as a factor and for
many in the sector the fear is there
will be more if nothing changes
so far ofsted's resisted calls to scrap
the single word judgments but those
calls for reform are only getting louder
reducing it to one single grade is is
nonsense I mean there's ample research
out there when we used to go and um
grade lessons that you may as well you
may as well just toss a coin
in terms of getting it accurate hello
yes Andrew here from Andrew Morris quit
is an ofsted inspector in 2015. he
claims teams would go into schools with
their minds made up already and would
change evidence to fit their
predetermined rating I can think of a
number of times a conversation has been
had with me that you know you might want
to go and rethink what you put in that
evidence form that doesn't reconcile
with with what your other colleagues are
seeing and that's not particularly
helpful in terms of us trying to get
through to the overall final grade so I
felt you know very uncomfortable with
that
in a statement ofsted said our
inspections are first and foremost for
children and their parents we always
want inspections to be constructive and
collaborative and in the vast majority
of cases School leaders agree that they
are
but many clearly feel this is a fatal
lesson that hasn't been learned either
Bennett Sky News Cheshire
a court in New York has heard closing
arguments in a civil lawsuit accusing
Donald Trump of rape and defamation the
former president denies the claims which
have been brought by former L magazine
advice columnist Eugene Carroll well
let's get more on this we can speak to
our U.S correspondent James Matthews in
Washington that James what's been said
foreign
by the attorneys for each and Carol
Donald Trump's accuser is that she has
presented credible consistent and
Powerful evidence around an incident she
says took place in 1996. she says that
she met Donald Trump outside a
department store in New York they ended
up inside he had asked her for advice in
buying a gift for a woman they were in
the lingerie department they went went
into a dressing room and it's inside
there that she says she was raped by
Donald Trump he dismisses it points to
the fact that she made these Revelations
many years after the alleged incident
took place he said she was trying simply
to sell a book calls her a hoax said
that these are false accusations against
a rich guy in the closing arguments by
her attorney
she presented video evidence the video
deposition of Donald Trump he didn't
give evidence in court in person but he
was asked questions on video now this is
a man who said he'd never met his
accuser and that in any case she wasn't
his type the attorney for Eugene Carroll
said well look at the video here's a
photograph that has Donald Trump in the
same frame as e Gene Carroll and when
presented with this Photograph on video
Donald Trump confuses his accuser with
his second wife Marla Maples according
to the attorney for Eugene Carroll that
shows that she was very much his type
look at the video
there's like Marvel's in this photo
that's Marla yeah that's that's my wife
which one woman are you pointing each
other now here
oh the person you just pointed to
him
and the person the woman on the right is
your then wife I don't know this was the
picture I assume that's John Johnson is
that because it's very blurry
there you go the jury is due to be sent
out in this case tomorrow it's very
important for all concerned not least
the woman at the center of an e Gene
Carroll significant for Donald Trump
bear in mind he's already facing charges
in connection with hush money payments
to a porn star he's also fishing facing
criminal investigations into other
matters related to the mishandling of
classified documents and into events
surrounding the January the 6th
Insurrection if a jury finds in favor of
his accuser and he successfully sued
that would cost him a lot of money it
would be also a hefty addition to the
legal burden that he carries
James in Washington thank you
Rescuers in Southern India have been
searching for survivors after an
overcrowded tourist boat sank in an
estuary in the state of Kerala around 40
people including children are thought to
have been on the boat police are looking
for the vessel's owner and have charged
him with homicide Sky's Neville Lazarus
reports
a late night boat tragedy has taken the
lives of several people including women
and children
The Vessel with at least 30 passengers
on board most on the summer holidays
capsized in the coastal town of tanoor
in the southern state of Kerala
one family lost 11 members in the
accident
some of the survivors are in critical
condition in hospital
the incident happened late on Sunday and
with Nightfall rescue operations were a
challenge
The Vessel has been pulled ashore and
Indian coast guards and the national
disaster relief Force were engaged in
looking for those still missing and
retrieving bodies From the Muddy Waters
many are believed to be trapped inside
when the boat overturned
an inquiry has been set up to
investigate the cause of the disaster
as the state government announced a day
of mourning and compensation to the next
of kin anxious relatives gather at the
hospital awaiting news of their loved
ones Neville nazareth's Sky News India